let's go to our caller from the 508 area
code maybe a
caller from the boston area caller from
508 what's your name where are you
calling from
hello david yes oh this is toby from
massachusetts
toby how are you i'm doing good my
question to you
is um do you think republicans will be
on board with
abolishing the electoral college if they
lose an election
if or if they win the popular vote but
lose the electoral college
well so two answers to that first is
yeah probably they'll probably very
quickly change their mind if the
electoral college ends up hurting them
so republicans benefit from the
electoral college we have a number of
cases including
in 2016 where the republican candidate
lost the popular vote but won
electorally and that's
part of why republicans defend it but
it's extremely unlikely to happen that's
the reality
and uh that many republican presidents
have only one because of the electoral
college and i mean listen
this november is an example trump is not
going to win the popular vote the
question is that he does he eke out an
electoral victory so i just don't think
we're going to see that anytime soon i
mean maybe you know in four or eight
years but
certainly this year biden if i were to a
betting man
i would bet on biden winning the popular
vote i don't know who's going to win
electorally
yeah because that's something i've been
thinking about i've been thinking about
the um
the national popular vote interstate
compact and i mean
i've been hoping that that is something
that gets through
in the near future even if it's not
likely because
the electoral college is such a broken
system yes
yeah so for people who don't know the
national popular vote interstate compact
what that is essentially
states who say instead of awarding our
electoral votes to whoever wins our
state
will award them to whoever wins the
national popular vote if you get enough
states together to do that
such that the total of their electoral
votes is 270 which is the number
required for the presidency
you've effectively made a national
popular
vote the the legal question around it
is whether some states are not allowed
to do that and that's an issue that's
come up recently by state constitutional
law
uh and obviously you know i'm not a
lawyer my formal training is in podiatry
so i would not be able to answer that
okay i guess we lost toby there toby did
toby had enough with me
and toby hung up